foreign
[Music]
representative Osborne moves at the
house adjourned from the session of June
15 2023. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye there's a
close nay the eyes have it
house will attend away Prayer by house
chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart pastor of
Saint Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester
good morning Mr Speaker
good morning New Hampshire House of
Representatives
let us be in an attitude of Prayer
good morning God
I ask that you bless this New Hampshire
House of Representatives today
as they complete their work in their
final session
bless each of these hard-working
Representatives as they worked so
diligently throughout the year
to do their best for those they
represent
guide them today in the debate and
decision process for all the matters
that are presented before them today
help them to be your wisdom today
this coming week
we celebrate the freedom of our country
and we thank you God that you are always
in our midst
in you God we do trust
oh God you are the great Jehovah
and I ask that you protect each member
and leader of This House of
Representatives as we complete our work
for the season
be with each member and I pray that you
keep them healthy and safe this summer
until we meet again
My Country Tis of Thee
sweet land of liberty
Of Thee I Sing
land where my father's died and land of
the Pilgrim's Pride
from every Mountainside Let Freedom Ring
oh God because of you
we are part of America the land of the
free and the brave
it is in your name O God that we pray
amen
do you recognize the member from Nashua
because I'm Linda and Harriet goth
writer who will lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Joe recognizes Reverend Renee Rouse who
[Music]
by the dawns
what so proud
[Music]
at the twilight's last
gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright
stars
[Music]
fight
or the ramp but we watch we're so
gallantly streaming
and the rockets
the bombs bursting
in air
[Laughter]
give proof
through the night
that our flag was still
there
Jose does that
Star-Spangled
Banner
yet we
[Laughter]
or the land
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
the house will attend to the request for
leads of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Connor Edwards Hamlet
hatch Juris and Seibert the day
important business Representatives Dolan
Gallagher Hicks Stephen Pearson Petrie
Richards and trottier the day illness in
the family Representatives cordelli
Finney crude home O'Brien and Alan
turcotte
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
I also attend to a reduction of guests
Mr Speaker please welcome Asia Rouse
guest of Representative Harriet
gathright Eleanor Rumbo guest of
Representative Rambo Carol cook and Paul
belea guest of Representative Doug
Thomas Mary Tommy and Andreas will be in
order
Mary Tommy and Andrew Nagel wife and
sons of Representative Nagel Hal rafter
and Joellen Courtney guests of
Representative tulersky Genevieve Graves
guest of Representative lewicki Paul
Tiana and Linda Murray Leanne Wang and
kudalin Son daughter-in-law grandson and
guest of Representative Kate Murray Anna
Marie and Riley Hussey Kristen and Katie
Goodrich and Trina Turner guest of
Representative Terror and Laura
landerman Garber guest of
Representatives Ming McGee and collabro
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend to a consent
calendar of Committee of confidence
none removed
are there any other reports that were
removed from the consent calendar then
Osmond moves at the consent calendar be
adopted are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the house will now attend to the regular
calendar of Committee of conference
reports on Senate bills
and recognize the clerk Mr Speaker
Senate Bill 61 relative to surface water
representative Aaron moves that we adopt
the committee across the report chair
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker
the last time I guess was about a month
ago I get up to speak about SB 61
I described to all of you what we saw in
the committee
and the influence of the industry that
made me step by step move to a position
where I couldn't support the bill that
was as it was written
since that time
some of you may have seen the article
that was in the Concord Monitor
this is also in a number of other media
Outlets we have received confirmation in
the form of emails between
lawyer for Casella waste management and
officials at DES which have confirmed
the suspicions that I and others have
had about how directly Casella has
shaped this process indeed dictated the
terms of the legislation that we are
voting on
I know this is a very controversial bill
but we're not going to allow
any
intent to be brought on to anybody
whether it be state employees whether it
be private people or whether it be a
lobbyist
so for all the members that are going to
speak on this bill keep that in mind
that that's not allowed
okay thank you Mr Speaker
each of us has a very difficult decision
to make today I don't pretend that this
is an easy decision to make for anybody
on either side of the aisle
what I want to say today is that whether
you vote in favor of the committee of
conference report or you vote against it
we have to think about what our
responsibilities are going forward if
you vote in favor of this amendment or
pardon me the the report and the bill it
has a two-year obeyance and that
two-year abeyance is not nothing I
concede that
but it is still our responsibility to
exercise all of the oversight
that we have been tasked with exercising
by the people who sent us here
we need to have an oversight Committee
in Ena environment agriculture we've
talked about that and we need to follow
it every step of the line from the
report that takes 120 days to the
writing of the rule process
seeing how much this bill has been
crafted by special interests only
reinforces how important that oversight
responsibility is
likewise if you vote against this today
the rules will expire in June of next
year at that point Des will have to
rewrite rules that is their
responsibility and it is our
responsibility to oversee it with or
without SB 61.
my concern is by as I have expressed
before is that the hiring of a
consultant which is favorable to the
industry will lead to a writing of rules
which is favorable to the industry
I was not elected by special interests
representing any industry I'm not here
to represent the interests of any
particular industry I'm here to
represent the interests of the people in
my districts and in the people of the
State of New Hampshire so whether 61
passes or it doesn't pass whatever side
you end up voting on what I implore you
to do what I implore this house to do is
to strenuously to vigorously exercise
our oversight responsibilities
every step down the line to make sure
that the rules we get are a lot better
than the bill we got thank you Mr
Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
I have clearly stated all the reasons SB
61 needs to be thrown in the trash pun
intended
SB 61 has always been bad for health and
the environment not only kicks the can
down the road but it kicks it in the
wrong direction
I'm not here to rehash any of the
arguments against it I'm here to present
new information we didn't have when we
voted
226-152 against my bipartisan floor
although there is obvious ethical issues
with drafting this legislation
throughout the six-month process to get
here I am more upset with the fact that
this influence and control is blatantly
putting the future and health and safety
of New Hampshire citizens at risk and
with all the new information we have
leading up to today there shouldn't be
one vote in this house to concur SB 61.
if you are stuck on the only argument in
support of 61 because of a two-year
abeyance on landfill permitting while
new rules are written here's why that
argument doesn't hold water
Des has repeated repeatedly said they
are already well into writing new
setback
site-specific setback landfill
permitting rules because the current
rules expire in July of 2024. so this
process is well underway
this bill is a hundred percent not
necessary why would we spend money on a
report which only hears from one expert
with one point of view versus multiple
points of view
if Des needs more expertise to complete
these rules the legislature can easily
provide that by holding a one-day public
hearing inviting all the experts to
provide all of their information the
data the models Etc to be compiled for
the agency over the last three years of
hearings we have tons of free and
readily available information from All
Points of View they can utilize to help
them
hey I'll even volunteer to compile it
all for them
sb61 guarantees a one-sided report
favoring the industry
stakeholders
why would we ever pay 200k for a
one-sided you know information which is
already free we know that the industry
already has the information in this
report that is like easily accessible
they could literally just grab it out of
a filing cabinet on a top drawer
the ENA committee knows this because
they have been hearing this information
for years now
so why is there a rush to pass this bill
which removes legislative oversight when
New Hampshire doesn't need another
landfill for at least 20 to 30 years
this body should easily see the agenda
here and answer that question
shouldn't our Focus next session be on
reducing the amount of out-of-state
trash we are taking in from States like
Massachusetts
the other body killed HB 56 with almost
no discussion and then insisted on
making more changes to their own bill
that we concurred with on June 8th
that's the only reason we're still here
talking about landfills but the changes
made the bill even more friendly towards
the one company at the heart of this
issue
the sad part is the bill actually got
better for the industry in the committee
of conference
so between January and June there was a
whole strong armed approach from the
Senate that they wouldn't take anything
from the house and then in the committee
of conference they actually changed the
conflict of interest statement and it's
now worthless it basically talks in
circles
I look forward to my colleagues on the
other side who will talk common sense
about their traditional core value of
protecting the environment while not
unduly burdening the industry
certainly the two Chambers can come
together in January and produce a bill
that offers some real protections for
New Hampshire surface water until our
state can produce a detailed setback
rule there is an obvious stop Gap
Improvement in the meantime
simply Des could change the ridiculous
200 foot uniform setback role to one
basically
the Department of Environmental Services
will choose a site-specific setback to
surface water in every individual permit
application from now on based on local
hydrogeologic conditions no new bill is
needed right now no taxpayer funds need
to be sent period end of story
when new information arises it's time to
change course let's make doing the right
thing popular again please vote no to
non-concur with SB 61 Mr Speaker I ask
for a division vote
please I Rise Again to talk about my
reservations with this bill
as indicated by my esteemed colleague
representative germana
and my other esteemed colleague
representative Potenza
there are problems with the process in
the process was entirely weighted on one
side
previously my colleagues had written a
good bill HB 56 but the folks on the
other side
killed the bill and gave us a study bill
it never made sense to me
now we know why the bill was so weak and
the process has gone from bad to worse
with the evidence in hand we now see why
the bill does not reflect the wishes of
the people who will be most affected by
it
the process was neither Fair nor
transparent
our committee was told that this bill
was not about a particular company
or a particular landfill but
respectfully evidence has proven to the
contrary
people who will be directly impacted by
this bill
do not want the bill
and they certainly do not want the
landfill
and they now have no confidence in the
process
they are not granted a seat in this Hall
we sit here as their representatives if
we do not represent their interest who
will
I now know that a bad Bill is really not
better than no bill
if this bill fails Des will have a year
and all the help they need to write a
better rule that is currently on the
books
and there are qualified scientists and
professionals with all the knowledge to
assist them for far less than two
hundred thousand dollars
meanwhile we will be watching going
forward we must do better than this
flawed process our natural resources are
the reason that so many people want to
live in New Hampshire
or come visit our state
only a fool seeks to foul his own nest
if it's true that the measure of a man
or a woman is what they do with power
let it be said that in advocating for
the rights of those who will bear the
burdens of the decisions we make here
they or foremost in our thoughts as we
weigh these decisions in accord with our
conscience thank you Mr Speaker
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker first of all this
is the last day and let me just say
thank you to all the representatives who
have shown me a freshman with dreadlocks
such respect in my first term in the New
Hampshire state house this is New
Hampshire and that's why we are here
so thank you
I rise today in support of non-concur on
this legislation because we have water
Warriors in the North Country who are
begging us to protect their water I rise
today because born and raised in New
Hampshire I'm going to be damned if I'm
going to let our water be controlled by
an industry which has no
qualms whatsoever for destroying our
land our environment and our our sea our
our Lakes
this is not Casella's body we are the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
we are elected by our constituents and
we none of us can go to our constituents
after passing a bill such as this and
say that we protected our environment
there is no rush here the people in the
North Country want us to kill this bill
that's exactly what we should do listen
to my colleague from Keen my colleague
who sits behind me and my colleague over
there from Manchester join us in
standing against Casella against
representative representative thank you
Mr Speaker the representative will
that was quite the speech to follow
the bill is amended by the house and I'm
going to read an important section and
talk about what the language means
this is in section three paragraph Roman
numeral 3A criteria for determining a
site-specific setback of a landfill
footprint from perennial surface water
bodies that would be lakes rivers
streams
right to prevent attenuate or otherwise
remediate the potential release of
contaminants teach Surface body of water
from the landfill footprint any rules
adopted by the department under this
paragraph shall in addition to other
factors the department deems necessary
for rules to provide adequate protection
adequate protection is that good enough
in a state where tourism is an important
element
where our rivers and streams and the
natural beauty of our state is something
we all want to protect
shouldn't that say something like Best
in Class protection
adequate doesn't seem good enough
we were put here by our our citizens as
the largest legislative body in the U.S
other than Congress
to represent their wishes
I would think that everybody in this
room wants to do their best to protect
our natural landscape to be good
stewards
of the environment
not necessarily to worship it but to be
good stewards of it so we protect it so
we can pass it on to our children I
would ask that you would oppose the
concar motion
and make sure the rules that are adopted
go through this body in particular in a
way that protects our our water bodies
Our streams and our Lakes thank you
thank you
SB 61 provides procedures for Des
rulemaking on setbacks between new
landfills and surface water bodies
the committee of conference agreed to
its version we passed two weeks ago
with an amendment we correct
typographical errors and clarifies the
language for the one-time extension of
the rulemaking deadline that was the
house version
this bill directs Des to hire one or
more Consultants to examine current laws
and rules and recommend updates to those
rules that take into consideration a set
of technical factors including soil
stratigraphy and permeability volume
gradients and travel time of groundwater
supplying the surface water body
bedrock lithology and structure
hydraulic conductivity and other factors
the commissioner of Des Bob Scott is in
favor of this bill
currently Des does not have the Manpower
or expertise to do this work alone
the bill this bill grants Des the help
they have requested without incurring
the cost of one or more new permanent
staff hires
third party assistance here makes sense
and it will be done through an RFP
process that has specific requirements
and language preventing any conflict of
interest as well additionally there will
be points along this rule making process
for public scrutiny and public input
the language in SB 61 was crafted by
senate members house members Des
business stakeholders the North Country
Alliance for balance change and other
parties
that is how legislation is normally
crafted in our committees and Chambers
we all know that nothing isn't done here
in a vacuum
SB 61 is written and amended by the
committee of conference is sound and
vetted legislation and will provide Des
with a much needed expertise and
assistance to update its current
it is very important to note
that during the process of establishing
new landfill setback rules and E and all
landfill permit applications will be
held in advance and when the rules are
completed within 24 months the permit
application must be modified to comply
with those new rules
if this Committee of conference report
is not accepted by you today
than any landfill permits can be granted
next week or next month this year or
next year with the old rules still in
place which includes a minimum 200 foot
setback from a body of water
that is not an acceptable option
by accepting this Committee of
conference report it will give the
landfill permit granting activity a
two-year pause with a one-time 90-day
extension if necessary
and that will happen right away
this bill is possible now
we can eliminate the current possible
to any body of water now
and we can give a two-year pause to
permitting now
while new rules are still being
developed
we must not let this important chance
slip away and I urge you my colleagues
to support and pass this Committee of
conference report now thank you thank
you Mr Speaker
Jenna patenza has requested a division
members take their seats
foreign
Senate bill 61. this is a division vote
share recognizes representative come to
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that Des is already in the
process of writing the rules and I have
been assured that they will be completed
in August of 2024.
in that the permitting process takes a
minimum of two years minimum
and Mr Speaker if I know that this is a
feel-good bill that we in the ENA
committee we're told that this would be
the only Bill the executive branch would
sign by someone at DES and that a
lobbyist for one of the parties
uh helped with the language
and Mr Speaker if I know that any
information given to Des by the
consultant can be ignored
let me repeat that can be ignored why
would I then spend two hundred thousand
dollars of taxpayer money
Mr Speaker if I know that as a member
who lives in The Lakes Region the
protection of our Lakes is not something
that we should take lightly
and finally Mr Speaker we are the
legislative branch
elected by our constituents
we are beholden to them not to the
executive branch not to an agency and
certainly not to any lobbying group
would I now press the red button for
non-concur thank you Mr Speaker do you
recognize representative Megan Murray
speaker
stakeholders input and that it includes
conflict of interest language a two-year
Urbane sunciting landfills and that our
rules process is open to the public with
stakeholders and that the rules process
has joint legislative oversight and if I
also know that a couple of weeks ago
this was our house position would I now
press the green button to accept the
committee of conference report thank you
has everybody turned on their voting
stations
make sure you do
the motion before us
is to concur on Senate bill 61. this is
a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
vote
household
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
134 voting a 100 238 voting a the
chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker Senate Bill 207 relative to
mental health critical incident
intervention and management and relative
representative goalie moves that we
advance the committee of conference
report
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye as opposed
May
I just have it maybe a conference report
house will be in order the house will
now attend to the cons house house wait
okay the house chair recognizes the
clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted the
committee of conference recommendation
on the following bills House Bill 119
relative to home Homestead food
operation Operation licensure and making
Provisions for the sale of meat from
uninspected bison elk or Red Deer House
Bill 211 relative to a report by the
department of energy on the
effectiveness of the system's benefit
charge in relative to surface water
setbacks for landfills and relative to
water quality House Bill 221 relative to
the acquisition of Agriculture Land
Development rights and relative to the
advanced deposit account wagering and
relative to the use of game cameras
House Bill 281 relative to least cost
integrated resource plans of utilities
Municipal hosts for purposes of limited
electrical energy producers the cost of
compliance with disclosure of electrical
renewable portfolio standards repealing
the Energy Efficiency and sustainable
energy board and procedures for energy
facility citing by the site evaluation
committee House Bill 358 relative to the
filing and Adoption of proposed
administrative rules and relative to
overpayment of unemployment compensation
relative to policies relating to nursing
mothers and House Bill 442 relative to
the house will now attended a consent
calendar committee a conference reports
on house bills
Mr Speaker the conference report on
House Bill 221 removed by
Representatives comtos Tom Manion coulon
verville Constable Potenza McCarter
Terry pole avalani the conference report
on House Bill 281 removed by
Representatives corpsman Munns
McWilliams Haskins Noel sellers Tony
leckis Alicia leckis Christine Perez and
Manos
are there any other reports to be
representative Osborne moves the consent
calendar be adopted are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed A you guys have it in the
further Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference which was referred the
following title bill House Bill 275
relative to schools approved for a
school tuition program by a school board
House Bill 315 prohibiting provocations
based on a victim's actual perceived
gender gender identity gender expression
or sexual orientation from being used as
a defense in a criminal case House Bill
409 relative to the organization of the
office of professional licensure and
certification and Adoption of the
interstate social work licensure compact
House Bill 536 relative to the Charter
Public School joint legislative
oversight committee and relative to the
Charter Public School use of unused
District facilities House Bill 611
relative the eligibility criteria for
the therapeutic cannabis program and
establishing a commission to study
state-controlled sales of cannabis and
relatives of prohibition on the sale of
hemp products containing certain levels
and how's Bill 75 relative to the
election of Stafford County
Commissioners
Mr Speaker House Bill 75 relative to the
election of Stratford County
Commissioners
representative Lynn turcott moves we
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make a
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I don't want to keep us here
any longer than necessary on our last
day but I Rise to speak against adopting
the committee of conference report on HB
75.
I was on that committee and my no vote
was discarded along with that of my
Democratic colleague on the other side
of the wall
but that's okay it happens it's in the
rules and we follow our rules
but with respect to HB 75 and it's body
double HB 270 which Municipal and County
government voted to retain somehow we
haven't followed those rules
regardless of what you've been told HB
75 is a redistricting Bill and
redistricting according to the rules
only happens once every 10 years
those rules also dictate that the party
in the majority runs that process which
is exactly what happened last year the
Republicans took charge of redistricting
the whole state including its County
Commissioner districts
they made no changes to Stratford County
when asked in last week's Committee of
conference why they didn't seek changes
when they had the opportunity to do so
one of the sponsors who was also a key
member of the House special committee on
redistricting said and I quote
there just wasn't time we were too busy
and it would have muddied the waters
the consequence of that decision was the
passage of HB 54 in November 2021
legislation that was part and parcel
over the overall redistricting process
HP 54 sets forth the county commissioner
districts in New Hampshire for the next
10 years
so why now when redistricting according
to our rules
is over are we back at it again
and how according to those same rules do
we justify going back in time to cherry
pick just one component out of the whole
process
I guess we have to take the word of HB
75 sponsor from the other side of the
wall when he said last week in response
to that question and I quote we're not
redistricting we're just creating new
districts for the commissioners
I don't know about you but that's a
little bit of a head scratcher for me
let's face facts we don't redistrict
counties outside the 10-year cycle
inside that cycle we may change what
County Commissioners can do under
existing law or whether they're elected
at large or by District but we don't
mess with the districts and we certainly
don't create new counties for the
Commissioners County districts for the
commissioners
we've been told that HB 75 is just a
simple attempt to apply consistency to
how counties govern themselves
and to bring Stratford in line with all
the others
but again if that consistency was such a
priority
Why didn't it come up
when why was it ignored last year when a
change could have been lawfully made
make no mistake this isn't just about
Stratford County because once we Stout
down the road of changing electoral Maps
outside the 10-year cycle we're entering
dangerous territory
throw away the rules and we'll all be
looking over our shoulders to see which
member of this house or the body on the
other side of the wall
suddenly sees problems in our community
or our County that require the Electoral
maps to be redrawn
let's not go there we don't have to our
constituents don't want us to we have
more important business to take care of
on their behalf let's stick to the rules
because without them all this becomes a
partisan free for all and the good work
we've done together in this session and
hope to do when the next will be subject
to a terrible precedent if this bill is
passed I urge you to vote no on
accepting the committee of conference
report for HB 75 and I requested
division vote Mr Speaker
chair recognized representative Lynn
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
everyone
it seems like a little bit of deja vu
here
so we're going to start out by talking
about
how I opened this last time and that is
Stratford County
is the only County out of our 10
counties in our states that do not have
commissioner districts
now during the COC an individual on the
other side of the wall proposed and
proffered a different districting map
notice I didn't say
redistricting but a districting map that
he believed the current Commissioners
and the supporters would find more
acceptable
that was definitively turned down
so what have we gotten instead
it's what I call fear grenades
fear-mongering
we've heard over and over that this is
unconstitutional factually
representative I guess fear mongering is
not a proper application to our
uh
anyway unconstitutional factually
incorrect
and those who have been making this
promo pronouncement are simply
regurgitating the belief of a 40-year
commissioner from Stratford County
who also believes every County
your county
should elect their Commissioners at
as we've said time and time again this
is not redistricting
this is districting the county just has
just has every other of the nine
counties in the states have done over
the past decades
and many of those guess what during
non-reddistricting years
now we hear
let the process work well guess what the
the bill originally started out in the
house committee
it was properly noticed it was a
properly noticed Committee hearing
it was followed by a properly noticed
Senate hearing and only a few spoke out
at our hearing
it was later that the calls for the let
the process work
came out
latest that we've heard and some of you
may have seen this in the lobbyist note
chaos instability will rule pure
nonsense we're not going to have chaos
and instability
this process has happened nine other
times in our state
and nobody has ever attempted to
redistrict after the 10-year
our County Stratford county is entitled
to the same election process that every
other County already enjoys
so by voting to approve the decision of
the committee of conference
the de facto gerrymandered elections for
County Commissioners that has gone on in
Stratford County for decades will come
to an end so I ask that you please
support the committee of conference
recommendation by pressing the green
button thank you Mr Speaker
for what reason does the member rise
Mr Speaker is a motion to Table in order
at this time it is an order at this time
I would like to move to place the bill
on the table and I request a division
vote
the motion before us is the place House
Bill 75 on the table
and this will be a division vote members
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 75 this is a division vote
members should be in their seats
chair recognizes representative stavis
if I know that redistricting at all
levels including County Commissioner
districts takes place once every 10
years and is controlled by the party in
power at the time
and if I know that that time was a year
ago when the Republican Party held a
sizable majority
and if I know that the Republicans who
oversaw that redistricting process a
year ago recommended no changes to
Stratford County though they now
suddenly insist such changes are
urgently needed
if I further know that HB 75 sponsors
claim that this bill seeks only to bring
Strafford County's commissioner
elections in line with other New
Hampshire counties though no such effort
was made last year when redistricting
was taking place
and finally if I know that this is a
partisan effort meant to change the
political makeup of the Strafford County
Commissioners outside of the mandated
cycle and against the rules that govern
how such changes can lawfully be made
when I now press the green button to
support this tabling motion thank you Mr
Speaker
do you recognize representative Lynn
turcott for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know Stratford county is the only
County of the 10 in our state that does
not have commissioner districts and that
this bill would Rectify that
disadvantage
and if I know that every other County in
New Hampshire has transitioned to
deathstrix for their Commissioners over
the past decades during times other than
the 10-year redistricting when the
10-year redistricting takes place
if I know Stratford County like every
other County in New Hampshire deserves
its Commissioners to be elected
utilizing districts
and if I know a commissioner of 40 years
in Stratford County believes York County
should elect your Commissioners without
districts and at Large
would I now press the red button so a
vote can be taken on the decision of the
committee of conference thank you Mr
Speaker
motion before us is the table House Bill
75 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
well members president had an
if all members had an opportunity to
vote
185 voting a 186 voting a the motion to
table fails we're back to the original
motion
of
accepting the committee of conference
the question is on the committee
conference report accepting house bill
75.
thank you
who called for a division representative
Weber calls for a division vote this
will be a division vote members take
motion before us is concurrent House
Bill 75 this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative magliore
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that county-wide
Services currently provided by the
Stratford County Commissioners are
available to all residents of Stratford
County and those budgeted services are
approved annually by the delegation many
times unanimously
and if I know that two previous bills to
create districts in Stratford County
when itl in this body
and if I know that we have heard
numerous times that there was a
conscious decision not to address this
issue of District districts for
Stratford County Commissioners when the
house was redrawing the lines for County
Commissioners during the decennial
and if I know that redrawing lines
outside of the 10-year window is thought
to be unconstitutional
and if Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill would create a precedent whereby
every County would be susceptible to
redistricting for County Commissioners
and executive counselors by the party in
the majority in any year
then Mr Speaker would I press the red
button to oppose the committee report
thank you chair recognize representative
thank you Mr Speaker
once again if I know that Stratford
County
is the only County out of the 10 in our
state that does not have a commission or
District
and this bill would Rectify that
disadvantage
if I know that during the redistricting
process
two years ago
that the decision was distinctly made
not to include this in the redistricting
process
and by seeing what has gone on on this
bill now I think everybody could agree
if I know Stratford County like every
other County
deserves to have their Commissioners
elected by districts
would I now press the green button to
support the unanimous decision of the
two legislative bodies of the committee
conference thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 75 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
representative
well
well ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
186 voting a 185 voting a committee
chair recognizes Mr Speaker
I just I would like sorry what reason
does a member rise I rise from the
person's purpose of just giving a
written protest about this bill uh to
the uh
that's fine it issue
pursuant to part two article 84 of the
Constitution you have the right to do
that
but the microphone
I'm not sure whether this should be two
motions or one motion because I want to
print last week's debate on uh on this
on HB 75 as well as this week's debate
you're making a motion to print the
printing the debate on both on 75 yes
from both both days to both days
motion is in order
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
suppose May the eyes have it will be
printed
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
House Bill 275 relative to schools
approved for a school tuition program by
representative lab moves that we adopt
the committee conference report on House
Bill 275 the chair recognizes
representative Miler to speak to the
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
callings I rise today to encourage you
to eject
the committee of conference on HB 275
every New Hampshire student should have
available to them a publicly a public
school funded through City
state and town taxes and not by
individual family bank accounts
75 focuses on middle schools and high
schools
it authorizes local school boards to
establish tuition contracts with another
public school or any private school
that the board approves
the school board would establish a
tuition-based cost
let's save fourteen thousand dollars
but if the alternative school tuition is
more let's say nineteen thousand dollars
a family choosing the alternative school
would have to pay the difference
in this example it would be five
thousand dollars
this is a wrong approach to providing a
free public education and violates the
historic tradition of a free public
education established by Horace Mann in
1839.
public schools have always provided
equity in educational opportunities for
students
recently the governor signed into law
SSP 77 which requires that school boards
approve a list of private schools with
tuition agreements
so with HB 275 and SB 77 every school
district would have to establish tuition
agreements with private schools or other
public schools and a minimum tuition
paid by the taxpayer
with two set with HP 275 a family
choosing a school with a higher tuition
would pay the difference with local
tuition monies coming from the public
schools this is a bad idea
HB 275 would increase the inequities in
educational opportunities where some
families who could afford to pay the
extra would get a taxpayer-funded
subsidy for a school that could provide
a different learning experience or a
special sports team access or
extracurricular activities while
families that couldn't afford to pay
more would be left
in unfunded and under-resourced schools
all of our 165
000 public school students deserve
well-funded neighborhood community
Public Schools where they can learn and
Thrive increasing inequities and
educational opportunities instead of
fully funding local Community Schools is
unfair to granted State students and
their families as well as taxpayers
finally colleagues there is little data
on the need for s for HB 275 there was
no Statewide data ever provided to
either the house education committee or
the committee of conference on the
breadth of the need for this bill other
than one specific School District
until we know the Exotic exact extent of
the need or this bill it is premature
and unwise for the legislature to act
accordingly
think hard about the vote we are about
to make
think about asking your constituents
especially those who are retired and
living on fixed incomes to dig deeper
into their property tax paid for because
they've already paid for public schools
further we need to work to ensure that
every Public School creates the best
learning opportunities for all students
to help all Spanish state families
without them having to pay additional
taxes tax tuition from their own bank
accounts I urge you to vote no and
reject the committee of conference
report on HB 275. thank you Mr Speaker
and I request a division vote
gee I recognize representative Ladd to
thank you Mr Speaker
I think we need to get our facts squared
away here
the committee conference addressed the
Senate version of 275 and amended it in
committee
the amendment looked at the tuition
school program
as it's established now
and all schools which are proved under
the school approval program for tuition
schools
sending districts to the receiving
District must be approved by the local
the version that we looked at that came
from the senate had the terminology of
anchor School within the terminology we
know that there's many k through eights
K through fours K through six is in this
state that don't have the grades beyond
the level which they have within the
re the residence School
so they tuition out they tuition to
other school districts
there are agreements contractual
agreements
that are approved by the sending board
and the receiving board for those
students which are moving out to one of
so the local board makes the decision
you may have four or five different
districts which you can tuition your
kids to
and there's many reasons why we have
multiple districts oftentimes approve in
the school tuition program
simply fact based upon these are small
districts many of them
and parents work in towns which are in
different directions
the receiving schools also have
different types of program offerings
some of these receiving schools may have
a Career Technical education built
within that school
they may have a wonderful theater
program
they might might have a wonderful
Athletic program and all our children
are different and unique and look to
this sources or the services in these
receiving schools which best fit their
needs
now a parent can't just walk up to the
school board and say I want my child
going to holderness or Kimball Union
or some other private school the school
that they we send kids to under this
program must be approved by the local
school board
so we took the word anchor school out of
it we looked in legislation there's no
such term yes there are a few districts
that use this terminology in their
policies
but we took it out and we put in wording
that there must be at least one option
in these contracts which are signed that
is
sending kids to
Public Schools or a public Academy
to be a public school you must be
approved by the state board you must be
also school that
provides all those academic standards
which are required by law
and you must be also a school that meets
the minimum School approvals for minimum
standards for school approval Public
School approval so we're talking about
one of those four options or five
options that District must must be one
of these schools so that every child in
the sending district has the option to
attend a school which meets their
services and their needs
this bill is not a partisan bill in
terms of the sending districts it's a
coming as a result a parent saying I
might work way over here in town X and
that's one of the approved schools but
over here in time why which is going the
wrong direction and in high school you
have to provide transportation I'd like
to be able to go over to this school and
transport my own child
but what's happened is some of these
receiving schools changed the amount of
tuition as every District in the state
does that the tuition costs are going up
and if the average cost might be
nineteen thousand dollars
and family X here has one child already
in that school system
but three years to four years later
another child comes along but in the
interim
that receiving school has changed their
tuition rate and it's now above the cap
of the sending District the parents
simply asking hey can I pay that
difference to have my whole family going
to the same location saving these
Transportation costs where I work this
is in fact happening in one of the
districts which I represent and the
other District the same issue is
occurring so it's more than one school
district that's encountering this in my
district there's just two out of the
five districts I represent what is it
like in your District
so what we're trying to do is
accommodate students here
some have also said well this is in the
wrong area statutory language it's in
the portion of deals with manifest
educational hardship this is not a
tuition program resulting upon
a pervasive severe or persistent
hardship the child's having in the given
school this is a result of the sending
school not having those grades in their
school
so there's real reason and causation for
us to move forward with this area of
statutory language and it is truly in
the best interests of family and
students
and our Workforce thank you very much
member does not yield
Senator Miler has requested division
this will be a division vote members
the motion before us is to Kerwin house
bill 275.
this will be a division vote
share recognizes representative luno for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know school districts that don't
operate their own schools May contract
with other public or private schools
under a tuition agreement at noid
additional cost to families
but if I know that this bill mandates
that all school districts establish
tuition agreements with other public and
private schools and that it could be
holderness or Kua or Brewster Academy
with some of the tuition paid by the
local property taxpayers including
seniors living on a fixed income
and if I know that this isn't a good
idea for kids families or taxpayers
then what I press the red button and
reject the conference report
thank you Mr Speaker do you recognize
your representative Ladd for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
provides that a parent May pay the
difference between a receiving school's
tuition cost and then sending District
tuition cap as long as the parent has at
least one other enrollment option that
is an approved public school or public
Academy at no cost to the parent
and if I know a school approved as a
tuition program School must be approved
and contracted by the local public
school board and must provide an
opportunity for an adequate education
and if I further know this Common Sense
Bill enables local boards to better
accommodate unique family scheduling
needs and will provide student learning
equity
would I then support effective family
oriented student tuition program
opportunities by pressing the green
button thank you
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 275. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
had an opportunity to vote
187 voting yay 185 voting a media
conference report is about
chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker House Bill 315 prohibiting
provocations based on a victim's actual
or perceived gender gender identity
gender expression or sexual orientation
from being used as a defense in a
representative Roy moves we adopt the
committee a conference report chair
recognized representative true to speak
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to speak against the Sea of sea
on House Bill 315.
as it sometimes happens
they who shall not be mentioned
just can't help but start tinkering with
a bill that is very well written
and that's what caused this house to
after it was changed by those
Who Remain unnamed
currently in New Hampshire an unwanted
sexual Advance would not need to be
forcible
for it to count as provocation
with the CFC text as presented a man
would need to physically lay hands on a
woman before she could cite in a trial
his unwanted sexual advances as
provocation
some people may say that the CHC Bill
does not limit in any way a person's
ability to make a claim of self-defense
except that is exactly what the Sea of C
Bill does
I say that if we accept and pass the CFC
report
a woman would not be able to cite
unwanted sexual harassment as a
provocation was she to kill a man and be
tried for murder
unless the man actually used physical
force on her
the CFC states that they carefully
crafted the language
from being used in New Hampshire
which of course the gay Panic defense
has never been used in New Hampshire
and for the CFC to offer protection from
the non-existent gay Panic defense
they have created a situation where a
woman must wait for a predator to
physically lay hands on her before the
woman can respond with protective
violence
they have created that
by inserting that a woman can't claim
extreme provocation and I quote
including in circumstances in which the
victim made an unforceable romantic or
sexual Advance towards the defendant
there are many circumstances under which
provocation could be very severe
without involving physical Force
if the CFC had wanted to ensure that
this bill accomplished its original
attempt then I believe what the Sea of C
should have done was pass the bill as it
was written when this house passed 315
on a unanimous Voice vote
back in March back in March
I asked you to please vote no on the sea
of C I request a roll call vote thank
you Mr Speaker
chair recognize your Belcher to speak
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I rise
in support of the committee of
conference report on this as you may
recall I had a problem with an earlier
version of of the bill because of of
certain language in the one particular
Clause of the bill that seemed to me
created the potential for unintended
consequences the committee report
completely eliminates that possibility
there's there will be no unintended
consequences the language has been
changed in an important way I have to
strongly disagree with the prior speaker
this this bill has nothing to do with
self-defense provocation is something
that is a mitigator when some this this
bill applies to one circumstance
somebody is charged with murder
and they assert not self-defense as a
defense but they assert what's known as
provocation not to have not to say that
I'm not guilty but that I'm guilty of a
lesser inclu of a lesser offense so that
instead of murder which carries a life
of potential sense of life imprisonment
I'm guilty of manslaughter which would
make the maximum spend sentence only 30
years still a very serious offense but
less than murder that's the only
circumstance that this bill applies to
it has nothing whatsoever to do with
self-defense and what this bill says in
effect
is you can't say if you're charged with
murder that is you've killed some
someone is dead let's make I make under
make clear what we're talking about
someone is dead and you're charged with
murdering that person and you can't say
to the jury
listen
find me guilty of a lesser offense
because the person that I killed in a
sense is less worthy that's the claim
the person I killed is less worthy
because he or she is gay or transgender
or or something like that can you
imagine that that it should be all right
in New Hampshire to say it was okay I'm
guilty for a lesser offense because the
person I killed because of the gender
identity of someone I killed that seems
to me it's outrageous this is this bill
makes perfect sense I urge the Comm the
the body to adopt the committee of
conference report thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
colleagues
I'll be absolutely honest in that I
didn't fully understand the predominant
argument
against this bill
but I have a very different one and I
see a different problem
our justice system was established in
such a manner as the place an immense
degree of trust
injuries
our system was established such that
juries can even nullify a law
if they believe that an injustice
is being done
our system was set up such that it would
prefer to see 100
guilty men go free rather than one
innocent man be imprisoned
now nobody likes the idea that a bigoted
but because something happened in
another state
decades ago
does not justify us putting our thumbs
on the scale of Justice by prohibiting
what a jury may be allowed to hear
this bill demolishes the arguments for a
trustworthy and impartial jury it
assumes that the presence of bigotry
will taint Justice
and in so doing it becomes a slippery
slope
toward further restrictions on what a
jury may be allowed to hear
I ask you to trust New Hampshire
citizens to render impartial Justice
and vote no on this thank you
I recognize representative Roy speak to
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
I'm just going to clarify what this bill
does and does not do because it sounds
like it's gotten very confusing
someone kills someone
they get to court they are charged with
murder
they wish to make the argument to the
jury that the jury should find them
guilty of manslaughter versus guilty of
murder and the theory they wish to
present to the jury is jury
find me guilty of manslaughter instead
of murder because the person I killed is
gay and therefore it should be okay
that is all that this does it has
nothing to do with self-defense it has
nothing to do with women being hit on
it's simply I killed someone and I wish
to tell the jury please find me guilty
of manslaughter and not murder because
the person I killed is transgender and
therefore it should be okay to kill them
that's all this bill would ban it would
ban someone from making that argument to
a jury
now whether or not you agree we should
be banning certain defenses to juries or
not I leave that to your personal
conscience but I'm clarifying what the
bill does and does not do it is very
limited to just that situation
thank you Mr Speaker
Senator has called for a roll call us
the division has been called for this
will be a division vote members take
the motion before us is occur on House
Bill 315 this is a division vote
chair recognized represent filio for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the committee
of conference recommendation only
applies to RSA
632 which is the manslaughter section
dealing with provocation and does not
deal with RSA 6274 which is the
self-defense statute and therefore
leaves the right to self-defense in
place regardless of the arguments today
and if I also know that the committee of
conference report uses the words because
of therefore meaning that the argument
in the committee of conference report
can only be used if the defendant is
arguing provocation because of sex
gender sexual orientation or gender
identity and if I also know that the gay
Panic defense is used every year
Nationwide and succeeds about a third of
the time and finally if I know the New
Hampshire way is to deal with problems
head on proactively and not reactively
do I then press the green button for the
committee of conference report to put
the gay Panic defense where it belongs
in the history books not the law books
thank you the motion before us is the
current house bill 315. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
or press the red button voting stations
members president had an opportunity to
vote
271 voting a 98 voting a committee
conference report is adopted
it's Bill 409 relative to the
organization of the office of
professional licensure and certification
and Adoption of the interstate social
then Carol McGuire moves that we adopt
the committee a conference report are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
supposed nay the eyes have it committee
conference report is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker Hospital
536 relative to the Charter Public
School joint legislative oversight
committee and relative to Charter Public
it was in lab lad moves we adopt
committee accomplish report and House
Bill 536 chair recognizes representative
luno
thank you very much Mr Speaker
House Bill 536 passed this chamber with
a strong bipartisan vote it was a good
bill but the other chamber amended it
and messed it up I signed off on the
conference report only because it made
the bill a little less bad but it's
still bad and it's bad State policy that
mandates the public school district sell
an unused taxpayer-owned school facility
to a privately owned Charter School
against the will of the locally elected
School Board
it's nothing short of a mandate to sell
taxpayer on property to a private
company
proponents talk about problems with the
current law
but examples they cite
and that I work ended up working out
just fine
with the charter school buying of the
unused facility no problem here the
existing law works as intended
but with this bill the commissioner of
Education sets the market price
and if there are no other offers the
locally elected School Board must sell
the public property to a privately owned
charter school for that Marketplace for
that market price or less
think on that one or less how much less
taxpayers paid for the land paid for the
building
paid to maintain the building paid to
renovate the building over the years
they'd want to know
they'd want to know how much less than
fair market value they're going to get
for their public property
maybe just a dollar
and with no other offers the privately
owned business gets to buy the
taxpayer-owned property for a buck done
deal
maybe the school district took the
building offline for a temporary decline
in enrollment
or maybe to renovate or maybe other
reasons like an interest in using it for
other community purposes maybe a
community center or a senior center or
an alternative high school maybe the
school board is waiting for the window
of opportunity to apply for State
Building Aid Grant and that could be
several years out
but the commissioner of Education could
sell the building for a buck
think this won't happen just look what
happened recently in tuftonborough where
historic public building was sold to an
Evangelical private charter school for
just one dollar
it's happened it's part of the grand
plan to destroy public schools and
decimate the strong best in the country
reputation New Hampshire has long been
known for
please don't lest the extremist pop
propaganda house will be in order lead
you to turn your backs on your friends
and neighbors I'm sure they'll want to
know who sold them out for a buck thank
you Mr Speaker and I requested division
vote
chair recognizes representative Vlad to
I think once again it's time to get our
in looking at the amending language
which is in this bill right now it says
if no agreement is reached the
commissioner of the Department of
Education shall engage an independent
mediator
so that the commissioner's not making
this decision
it's made by a mediator
and what we have here let's start right
from the very beginning when we're
talking about these vacant schools
all over this country because our
demographics are certainly dropping like
a lead balloon here from 220 210 000
kids when I first got in this joint and
now down to 161 000 kids Statewide we
have empty buildings out there and those
buildings have been maintained by public
dollars all along the way
in fact some were built that way
and when we have a vacant School
and as an administrator you sit there
looking at this vacant structure falling
apart because what are you doing you're
deferring maintenance
that's going to go to the schools to
have the kids in
and so the building the value of that
building keeps dropping and dropping and
dropping
so we have legislation in place right
now
where these vacant schools can be put on
the market with the option of first
that's going to offer a purchase price
or at least would be a Charter Public
School wow what an Innovative idea
have public school kids going back to a
public school that's been closed because
public school kids are in charter
schools let's not forget that
so what this bill does it puts a
timeline in which the negotiation
process goes on
fine everybody agrees to that in fact
everybody on the committee at conference
agreed
to this report
now I hear we don't agree
it's a little less better or whatever
was said
I I feel that at this point in time once
the mediator offers a free market price
he's not telling it that we took out
where it has to be accepted or rejected
just offers a free market price
for leasing or purchasing that facility
so the bottom line on this bill is that
we want to use these buildings
for public school kids
regardless of where you live
there are students in this state
that are taking advantage of the options
and the programming that are available
due to a number of reasons I won't go
through all the variables and all the
issues of why children choose Charter
Schools but just please remember they
are public schools and we should be
using them a vacant School falls apart
I can understand a school district
that's going to use the building in case
they know they have another facility is
falling apart and they're going to have
to move the kids in there while we fix
the roof for whatever for a year that's
legit but when his sister idle for so
long we got to do something about it and
this is a wonderful solution and this
committee conference report is right on
I ask that you support the report thank
you very much
as a member of yield the questions
the motion before us is the committee at
representative luno has requested a
it
is
clear
the motion before us to accept the
committee accomplishments report on
House Bill 536 this is a division vote
chair recognizer representative Tanner
if I know the original bill on
legislative oversight that passed in
this house on consent was changed by
adding an unrelated amendment that
mandates that a public school district
Sells school facilities
against the will of the locally elected
School Board
and if I know that this amendment
further puts our Department of Education
in the position of dealing with real
estate and appointing someone to set a
fair market value
for these local real estate sales and
transactions would I now vote red to
stop this overreach by the state and the
Department of Education in decisions
that should be made by the local
taxpayers and their elected School
boards please press red
thank you
chair recognize representative Ladd for
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
all members of the committee conference
is seated to the Senate version as
amended before you today
and if I know decisions are made by
public bodies to school boards
and if I believe that Charter Public
Schools are public schools that offer
another challenging public education
experience for New Hampshire students
and Families
would I then support the bipartisan
Committee of conference report by
pressing the green button thank you
the motion before us is the Kerwin House
Bill 536 this is a division vote you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your opposal press the red button
okay
all set is everyone president an
opportunity to vote
household attend household tender to
stay to the vote and the speaker did
vote
in the affirmative
chair recognizes the clerk speaker House
Bill 611 relative to eligibility
criteria for the therapeutic cannabis
program in establishing a commission to
study State Control sales of cannabis in
relative to the prohibition on the sale
of hemp products containing certain
levels of THC
way on
representative Leon was adopt the
committee of Commerce report
on 6 11. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye Mr opposed
nay you guys have it committee a
we'll now move on to Bill's removal from
the consent
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
House Bill 221 relative to the
acquisition of agricultural land
development rights and relative to
advance deposit account wagering and
completely
representative Aaron moves we concur
when House Bill 221
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
I suppose May the eyes have it and
committee at the conference report is
adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
House Bill 281 relative to least cost
integrating resource plans of utilities
Municipal hoes for purposes of limited
electrical energy producers the cost of
compliance with disclosure of electric
renewable portfolio standards repealing
the Energy Efficiency and sustainable
energy board and procedures for energy
facility citing by the site evaluation
committee
suppose
representative host moose we adopt the
committee of conference report on 281
chair recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker I'm just going to
speak on one portion of this bill that
has to do with the revising the rules
for the site evaluation committee I
believe I'm the only one in the house
that's actually served on one of these
and I served on six or seven of them and
the process we have is not very good
it's very slow very cumbersome it needs
to be fixed I was at a ferc meeting in
Maine last week and talked to people in
Industry about building projects in New
England and New Hampshire as well and
the basic sentiment is is we don't want
much built anywhere and one of the
reasons is our citing process is so
difficult the latest uh Power one that
was under this was the Antrim wind plan
which took two applications in six years
to get permitted and that's a basically
average is an output of about nine
megawatts so for nine megawatts it took
six years that sends a message don't
come to New Hampshire so we need to fix
this this is anybody's was in favor of
any type of new transmission New
Generation that includes Renewables if
you're in favor of the offshore wind
projects they all are going to need
transmission if you sign the letter on
the two states transmission project
that's recently been sent around that
would have to go to the site evaluation
committee as well as any other
transmission project we're not saying
that it should be a rubber stamp but the
thing needs to be made better it needs
to be more efficient there's a lot of
discussion about this and things it does
and doesn't do it doesn't take the
Public's ability to get involved away
there's still a provision in there for
the Attorney General
appoint a public Council which would
represent everybody anybody that wanted
to send in letters could do that also if
you're in the community where the
project is being built you can get
together with your neighbors or by
yourself we recognizes intervening get
full intravenous status in these
hearings so you can actually go in and
not only testify but cross-examine other
Witnesses so this is not a perfect bill
it doesn't completely make the process
fantastic but it's a needed step in the
right direction if you want to see new
generation especially most of that's
going to be renewable so if you're in
favor of renewable generation and the
transmission needed to get it to the
Geo recognize representative partial to
while I am loath to delve into five
portions of this Franken bill
as legislators we deserve to know what
is bundled in this legislation so I will
do my best to be brief
first
it requires the uh first it repeals the
requirement for utilities to submit a
lease cost integrative resource plan
also known as LC IRP don't remember that
they say they submit this with the
Public Utilities Commission and these
are big words that provide New
Hampshire's assurance that our energy
Supply is adequately planned for and
delivered at a reasonable price
with recent established from the
Department of energy a gutted Public
Utilities Commission is no longer the
best repository for these plans and I
would agree on that however it does not
mean the utilities should not consider
rate payer costs in determining our
future needs
even in a decoupled utility Market
by dereliction of our oversight on lease
cost planning any stranded costs for bad
investments will certainly be passed on
to the rate buyers
and in this age of skyrocketing Energy
prices we need proper oversight to
ensure reasonable planning
much of the public testimony wisely
advocated for some long-needed reform
including utilities and our consumer
advocate but nobody advocated for its
elimination
another aspect of this ranking bill is
the other silly notion that having a
department of energy provide a rough
average cost of the renewable portfolio
standard
nor customers yearly electric bill
is a good idea
the cost will be calculated and printed
once a year and have no relationship to
any portion of your specific bill
neither will there be any context for
understanding the
readable renewable portfolio standard
as a legislator I'm not sure if anybody
to explain this to any of my
constituents and if I had my brothers I
would see this legislation remained
where we had earlier voted at as a
sadly this legislation also dissolves
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board more big words easy board
and it returns those responsibilities to
the Department of energy
the easy board is a volunteer resource
of respected leaders from all energy
sectors
it will not be reproducible with the
confines of the Department of energy
that is already claiming Staffing
shortages and budget challenges
fourth portion of this Franken bill
poses changes to site evaluation
committee process
now we do need to streamline site
evaluation
but abolishing public input in favor of
severely downsized puc it's not
streamlining the process but rather
steamrolling our constituents
this portion of the bill had numerous
unbetted amendments before being
retained by committee
one reason for its retained status was
over the lack of a fiscal null which I
see is still missing from the current
bill you'll be asked to vote on
now this bill does get one thing right
it removes requirements small energy
producers be located in the same
municipality as group members
a town with high energy needs will now
be able to join adjacent municipalities
that may have other resources but not
the same power demands this is an
excellent bit of legislation that should
have passed on its own merits
rather than gutted and been taken hard
as passage by this Franken bill
and this is also that little piece of
cheese that's the bait
now know that in the past I've advocated
uh for any clean net metering bill and I
will continue to do so we do need a
clean net metering bill but this is not
it
now taking uh these five infrastructures
seem to have something for everybody to
hate clearly bundling bad legislation
does absolutely nothing to improve it
now I'd like to give one final reason
for non-concurrence
we already voted this bill down earlier
this month
forcing it through a committee of
conference that produced no changes
whatsoever shows a profound lack of good
faith and should be recorded accordingly
please vote red for non-compliance and I
request a division Vault thank you
do you recognize your representative
the house and the other bodies conferees
in the committee of conference
spoke eloquently about how this bill was
a classic example of a bipartisan
compromise
it provides policy Provisions that many
of our citizens and constituents want us
it provides a way for municipal
taxpayers to seek some relief by
installing renewable energy projects in
their towns and those projects can span
multiple towns with the passage of this
bill
not only do Municipal taxpayers benefit
from that but labor unions want to see
this bill passed as well because they
but this bill goes much farther than
just
removing Municipal boundaries from the
municipal group net group net metering
host
this bill also removes some burdensome
regulation that is driving up costs for
ratepayers
and that's an important
step forward
for the policy the energy policy of our
state
my distinguished College colleague from
Stratford talked about the SEC reforms
that are in this bill so I won't talk
about those but they are also important
reforms
together
it's a package of good energy policy
reforms that both sides can embrace
zenovos has requested a division
this will be a division vote members
[Music]
the motion before us is to occur on how
to concur on House Bill 281. this is
going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative corpsman
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the version of
this bill that the house passed had only
to do with least cost integrated
resource planning
and if I know that the version of this
bill passed by the other body
tacked on three other unrelated house
bills and parts of a fourth and that two
of these tacked on bills were retained
in the house science technology and
energy committee so that they have not
been discussed in the house as a body
and if I know that the motion to concur
with the version passed by the other
body failed in the house
and if I know that the house voted to
send this bill to a committee of
conference by just a single vote
and if I know that the committee of
conference made no changes whatsoever to
the version that the house did not
concur with
and
not only do I know these things but we
all do because everything I've stated is
fact and not a wit of opinion
then Mr Speaker would I press the red
button and vote against adopting the
committee report
okay I recognize Trump Senate votes for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that house bill 281
encompasses a significant bipartisan
compromise that provides important
policy policy provisions
for all of our state citizens
if I also know that this bill allows
cities and towns to use renewable energy
systems across Municipal boundaries a
change desired by municipalities labor
unions and clean energy advocates
and finally if I know that this
compromise also reforms or removes
regulatory systems that impede energy
development or drive up its costs
what I now reduce administrative burdens
while supporting local property
taxpayers by pressing the green button
thank you Mr Speaker motion before us is
to occur on House Bill 281 this is a
division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposal press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members president an opportunity
to vote
250 vote a day 121 voting aided
we're going to be doing the adjournment
motion but we have some special things
that are happening right after that so
chair recognize the member from Auburn
representative Osborne promotion to
adjourn from the early session result
that the house now adjourned from the
early session that the business of the
late session be in order at the present
time and when the house adjourns today
it be to meet at the call of the chair
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Mr Paul's name you guys have it the
motion is adopted
okay
this is a declaration and recognition of
Jack Sheehan
whereas Jack has been a part of the
sergeant of arm staff since 2009 and is
now retiring after 14 dedicated years of
service
whereas Jack was recommended for the
position by then door keeper Walter
sword who has known Jack for many years
as both were basins and knew that Jack
was Dependable with solvent work ethic
whereas Jack proved that he could be
relied upon it was always there whenever
needed regardless of time or day whereas
he arrived as scheduled and stayed for a
long as needed whereas it be that set
house sessions house hearings Senate
hearings caucuses putting four
amendments in seat Pockets he remained
on the job without complaint and whereas
occasionally his wife joined the
sergeant of arms staff assisted them
with placing four amendments in the seat
pockets and that was most appreciated
now and before be it declared the Jack
and his capacity as door keeper will be
missed by his colleagues fellow and
staff members and all legislators whom
he has worked with be a further declared
by virtue of the signature inscribed
below the House of Representatives does
publicly thank Jack Sheehan for his
long-standing public service to the
general court of New Hampshire in the
state and we wish him the best in his
future endeavatives
yes
[Applause]
foreign
move that the remarks uh honoring uh our
friend be placed in the permanent
the chair recognizes representative
moffatt magliari for the purposes of
thank you Mr Speaker but most
importantly thank you to everyone in
this body for the support for the
donations the contributions to a truly
wonderful outing uh the fact that we had
phenomenal weather uh I think everyone
was praying for that and we had no rain
the fact that we had so many
participants and volunteers but again
the generosity that we had from this
body and from all those who contributed
made this truly a wonderful wonderful
event I'm going to hand it over to
representative Moffett and then we're
going to hand an an incredible amount of
checks and money over to Liberty house
representative Moffett
thank you representative magliore or
maggiori
Mr minority leader you still here uh if
the representative of Manchester would
make the circuitous journey to this side
of the podium we would appreciate that
and while he's on his way uh you may
[Applause]
as was famously said in the movie
Casablanca a precedent has been broken
okay
real quick there were three Miracles
that happened last week or so there was
a miracle budget which has been signed
into the law the second Miracle which
representative Maggiore alluded to is
100 chance of rain on Monday and yet it
did not rain until we finished the gulf
and until Senator Lang gave away the
last
uh
six pack of beer which many were given
away
in a great deal of money was was raised
almost thirty thousand dollars and after
expenses almost over twenty thousand
dollars
[Applause]
oh and the third Miracle uh was the the
other represented from Loudon who had
not played golf in 23 years hit the pin
on the putting contest three miracles in
one week here's our shirt
and our folks are here representative Mr
minority Mr majority would you make the
Mr
majority leader
this is big enough to sleep in okay I
need it these days and finally
uh Jeff Nelson from Liberty house and
Ashley
[Applause]
and also here I see The Honorable JP
marzolo former representative who was
with
Liberty house
[Applause]
yeah it's
accepting on behalf of Liberty House
[Applause]
we have some announcements so please do
everybody stick around for a couple of
minutes the ice cream will still be out
there when you go out
thank you Mr Speaker brother Masons
brother Masons we didn't meet last month
we hope to meet this month let's meet at
cheers for some refreshment at six
o'clock cheers that's a couple blocks
down from the store Street Garage and
then we'll meet at if you don't want to
meet for the meal meet us at the lodge
just before seven o'clock on Ironworks
Road brother Masons will meet tonight
thank you
chair recognize representative Sanborn
for announcement
just want to thank everyone from the
house Ways and Means Committee for all
their hard work this year and invite
them to a group photo on the State House
steps immediately after the seersucker
photo that'll be in this room thank you
do you recognize the representative
good
nap I would like to invite all the
Nashua reps
to congregate on the front steps after
the last group and right after the
chair recognize Representative Steven
so the Sullivan County delegation will
meet for no more than five minutes right
over there as soon as we're done for the
purpose of ratifying our budget
convention minutes
Joe recognizes a clerk
thank you Mr Speaker a couple of few
quick brief bullet points the ice cream
social will be outside it is at the
Upham Walker house so please uh after
you are done here head over there
um and that's where it is please empty
your seat pockets and your mailboxes as
you're leaving today there is as you
know a a big trash bin a recycling bin
excuse me in the back where you can drop
your paper uh for those of you that wore
seersucker today we're doing a photo
after session right up here please come
up right immediately after session uh
Black Books will be in your mailboxes
over the summer when we come back in
September for veto day they will be
there this week will be the last week
that the calendar is mailed every week
beginning next week we will be
alternating weeks for the calendar the
Senate and the house alternate their
weeks so if you are on a statutory or a
study that is a senate or or a house one
if if it it will be posted in in one
version or the other every week and
again we do have a few unanimous
consents so please stick around
chair recognizes representative Ford and
Wheeler
thank you Mr Speaker on June 19th 2023
many of us enjoyed the federal holiday
known as Juneteenth but many still do
not know why we would celebrate this
important milestone in American history
freedom
that is what Juneteenth is all about
Juneteenth marks a pivotal summer Day in
1865 on June 19th when black people in a
stronghold of slavery Texas were told
they were free as more than two years
after President Abraham Lincoln had
signed the Emancipation Proclamation a
month after General Lee surrendered at
Appomattox Courthouse ending the Civil
War
Juneteenth is about freedom
New Hampshire is rooted in Freedom for
black people and freedom for all
people of African descent have been
living in New Hampshire since the first
enslaved Africans were unloaded onto our
Shores more than 370 years ago
I would suggest if you haven't already
visit the black Heritage Trail in
Portsmouth to learn more about how the
black people even in the shadows lived
starting in 1840s John P Hill a
Rochester native and a political force
in his time spoken almost every New
Hampshire town and village with a
resounding anti-slavery message a
freedom message
John P Hill is one of only a few
immortalized and statue on the State
House grounds
in 2019 The Honorable Senator Melanie
levette the state's first black state
senator helped move Senate Bill 174
Juneteenth legislation to the governor's
desk
through RSA 413 double A granted Staters
are now asked to remember and reflect on
Juneteenth on freedom
New Hampshire is rooted in Freedom
freedom to live to pursue happiness and
to prosper
lettuce on this last day of the
legislative session and in the month of
pride in Juneteenth and days before the
4th of July that we remember that
freedom for all does indeed mean freedom
[Applause]
I'd like to make a motion Mr Speaker I
moved to print the remarks of the
previous speaker in the permanent
journal without a doubt without
objection can I make another one as well
uh I
well this is a different motion I'd like
to motion to move the make the the
remarks on 61 to put them in the
permanent Journal if I could
without objection thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
um I'm just here real quickly to talk
about this guy right here
who I've had the pleasure to know for a
long long time and as most of you know
he's an avid motorcyclist and I keep
telling myself that's his real passion
but unfortunately this is also his
passion and it took him away from our
press conference at the beginning of
motorcycle week when we wanted to
present him
with
this
to show not just the appreciation of the
association I work for up in Laconia but
for all the tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of motorcyclists that
committed a state because the speaker my
friend Sherm has spent the majority of
his life making New Hampshire a very
welcoming place for all these visitors
to come here and most importantly for
the motorcyclists that live in this
state so thank you and I'll give you
this
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
for what reason does a member rise
I Rise to move the remarks of our friend
from Laconia be printed in the permanent
Journal
thank you Charlie
when I have known each other for well
over 40 years we've been dear friends
for a long time and I know that'll
continue for as long as we're both
do you recognizes representative Simpson
thank you speaker
and good afternoon friends I know we
want to get out of here soon and enjoy
the weather while it lasts but I am here
to speak on pride month which is the
month of June and I welcome any lgbtq
plus Representatives who would like to
join standing us with us at the well to
come up now you may
on June 28th in 1969 the patrons of
Stonewall Inn a dive bar an lgbtq Haven
in New York fought back against the
police raids being used to harass
intimidate and Rob the patrons of the
pub
days of resistance followed in the
streets
which was the Catalyst to the
Contemporary lgbtq Rights Movement
the following year people across the
nation held parades commemorating the
events of the Stonewall Inn
these annual celebrations are what we
know today as Pride parades
during the month of June lgbtq plus
Americans stand together in solidarity
and strive as we strive towards a more
perfect Society with the recognition
that each of us is created equal and
simply seek liberty and justice for all
this pride month as always we recognize
and celebrate lgbtq plus people who have
struggled for the right to live their
lives free from oppression and
discrimination
and we remember and honor those who have
died in the face of prejudice
last month we lost a young member of our
local community to depression and
bullying
on May 17 2023
14 year old Nova Dunn walked to the
overpass of Interstate 293 after school
I will leave you with these powerful
words shared by Novus family's friend
during the funeral
Nova went into her cocoon and emerged a
beautiful butterfly a transgender male
Nova was struggling but happier than
they that they had discovered who they
are
unfortunately not everybody is accepting
and that led to a lot of pain in this
beautiful child's life
though in pain and darkness Nova
continued to shine his light on everyone
he loved chorus and drama he joined
student government where he helped to
plan and carry out fun events for his
fellow students as well as Charity
fundraising for his community
did you know that a butterfly's average
lifespan
after emerging is roughly 14 days
Nova's lifespan was 14 years
that beautiful butterfly spread his
wings and flew higher than he has ever
flown before
Nova had a mission and he left that
mission in his parents hands he longed
to live in a world where being different
being gay and transgender was accepted
and understood that choosing to be
himself was a personal choice and not
one that hurt anyone else
that the need to bully someone over that
choice is not okay and not needed he
wanted a kind world
the best way to remember Nova is to be
an advocate an advocate for mental
health awareness an advocate for lgbtqa
Community if you see something say
something but most of all be kind
thank you and happy Pride we now invite
the deputy minority leader Alexis
papers across dozens of New Hampshire
cities and towns Portsmouth Nashua
Windham Lebanon Manchester the White
Mountains and more held celebrations
honoring our vibrant lgbtq plus
community
many of us in this room attended one or
multiple of these celebrations bringing
our children dogs and other loved ones
to join in the festivities it was not
that long ago within most of our
lifetimes that the first Pride March
took place in New Hampshire in
1981. that first year there were only
seven attendees
and here we are now thousands together
rallying in allyship and support across
our state and Across the Nation
at a time when the very identity and
Humanity of lgbtq plus people are under
attack just as recently as two weekends
ago here in Concord at a family Story
Hour event it is more critical now than
ever for us to acknowledge the
importance of pride month
New Hampshire has a proud history of
support for lgbtq plus people
in 1989 this body passed legislation for
legal guardianship for same-sex couples
that same year we passed housing
protection for people with AIDS
in 1997 we banned workplace
discrimination based on sexual
orientation
in 2009 New Hampshire was the first
state to enact legislation recognizing
civil unions without a court order
in 2011 we were the fifth state to pass
marriage equality
in 2018 we passed a bill to prevent
discrimination against transgender
people and we were the 14th state to
pass a ban on conversion therapy
over the last 30 years no state has
elected more members of the lgbtq plus
Community than New Hampshire voters we
have elected school board members
Selectmen City councilors Alderman mayor
over 70 state legislators and senators
and executive counselor and a member of
Congress
today the latest polls show that more
Americans and more Granite Staters than
ever support non-discrimination
protections for lgbtq plus people
I'm proud to stand in this chamber
beside our colleagues to unequivocally
share my support for our lgbtq plus
community and to say you are welcome and
you belong here in this state in our
statutes and in this chamber thank you
[Applause]
please for what reason did memorize uh
to make motion
I move that the remarks from the deputy
leader be placed in the permanent
journal without objection actually from
the entire unanimous consent we got it
thank you
speaker I just wanted to put a good word
in for uh holiday cards for the military
challenge Laura landerman uh Garber
how's this oh yes all right
um I just wanted to put it in a good
word for the holiday cards for military
challenge it was started about five
years ago by Laura Lanham and Garber as
of now they've sent out 850 000 uh cards
to the military and the goal is a
million um so I asked that everybody
grab a card on the way up thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker
and thank you colleagues I'll be brief I
know that I'm between you and summer
vacation
I represent the nine towns of Solomon
District 8 including my hometown of
Croydon I Rise to speak about the
widespread road damage that occurred
during the recent many heavy rainstorms
and affected many communities throughout
the state
Croydon received 5.8 inches of rain in
several hours last week
and then yesterday we got an additional
two inches in less than 20 minutes
there's a moat between my driveway and
the road and that's minor compared to
the rest of the impact
the road damages in Croydon will cost
over one and a half times our annual
Town budget so we are working with
director Buxton at New Hampshire
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management to hopefully qualify for a
FEMA application
we meet the county minimum it's not
clear yet whether we meet the Statewide
minimum that is needed to be eligible
for FEMA
so a survey has been sent from director
Buxton to all communities asking that
any storm damages that occurred within
the time period from June 16th the
beginning of this series of wet weather
be submitted even if your communities do
not appear to have enough damage that
you would qualify for help
they're trying to aggregate the impact
to approach it in that way which is
legitimate to do so I am just asking
each of you to please encourage your
community emergency directors to fill
out the survey that was emailed this
Monday the 26th and I thank you all for
your help and also for the incredible
[Applause]
represent Osmond moves at the house
stand in recess for the purpose of
enrolled Bill's Amendment rolled bills
reports and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
calls nay the eyes have it the house is
in recess to the crawl of the chair
May everybody have a wonderful safe
summer